[Music]
hey everyone davolo here and today we're
finally back after a few months break
from chainsaw man to get straight into
the dating dingy art from the academy
Saga or part two for those who like were
curious as to where I was would change
the man because I I did see your
comments asking what hadn't uploaded
anything I had to wait for those
chapters to build up and allow myself to
fully binge the series so that I could
drop a few videos in a row after I
completed my chainsaw man fasting I can
say that it was more than worth it I
always enjoyed sitting back and having
my mind completely blown with just how
creative this man actually is and this
Arc is no different it might be slower
in some parts but we get to see an Old
Devil friend us are indigenous
characters finally connect on a
different level and damn the
foreshadowing as to what comes up next
is actually mental so if you want more
chainsaw man content help push this
video to 5K likes so I know you're all
Kane on the next Arc And subscribe if
you are new around here but either way
sit back and relax as we watch asimataka
make a complete fool of yourself
so kicking things back off inside of
that silly old aquarium dingy still
stuck with Asa explains to her that the
eternity devil has taken over the entire
building but she refuses to believe him
having walked over 100 meters in a
straight line ASA wonders how long the
hallway is dingy tries to convince her
that it is the eternity Devil's thing
still she screams at him to shut up as
she can't believe the fact that Genji is
even a devil Hunter instead asking him
to stop making things up or confidently
claiming that she knows more as she's
actually in the devil Hunter club for my
distance the devil Hunter club members
then all pull up alongside and even back
up ASA by revealing that she actually
knows a lot about Devils while dingy who
you know by the way has no idea who the
devil Hunter club members are Haruka the
president of the group introduces
himself but immediately gets cut off in
a Savage manner by denji who notices
that Yoshida actually showed up as well
standing there Yoshida tells dingy that
he ended up in this whole mess just
because he wanted to check out some
fishes at the aquarium they got trapped
there instead by a nasty devil say or
Siggy I I really don't know this guy's
name I apologize and forms your cheater
that he got who just turned up now turns
out to be the guy who went from civilian
devil Hunter to Public Safety devil
Hunter while still in high school again
the student council president introduces
himself but just like last time he's cut
off as kabini's brother hagashimaya
shows up and reveals that this isn't a
dream they're being attacked by a
real-life devil on top of that he
reveals that he never really wanted to
join the devil Hunter club and that he
only did so because his mother said it'd
get him a scholarship I love the
freaking fact that for some reason this
is so similar to the first time that we
ever met the eternity Devil with kobini
freaking out but now it's her brother
here and everything but also so
different as pretty much every like
fossil of this story has changed in some
kind of way anyways let's explain that a
devil's power makes the hallway go on
forever and the only way out is if they
kill the devil or themselves wanting to
know if they saw any Devils beforehand
denji asks only to be told no I still
remembering what the famine devil had
previous basically told her wonders she
should turn dingy into a weapon or kill
Haruka who she believes is the real
Chainsaw man USA fullon believes that if
she can actually kill him then she could
get her own body back from yodu without
turning anyone else into a weapon moving
forth through the building now the
members of the devil Hunter Club are
able to obtain fish and water from an
endlessly repeating staff room that they
found together they eventually figure
out a way to cook by starting a fire
with someone's lighter and they scrapped
newspapers that were lying on the ground
a few moments later us reveals that she
can't actually eat fish since it looks
too much like a dead animal and it
totally grosses her out she hardly
leaves the room in size in front of the
door before bumping into dingy who gives
her a suspicious look it turns out that
dingy was just picking up a thousand yen
bag from the ground but ASA accuses him
of being a thief filled with ill-content
for our vomit eating creep ASA gives
dingy a moral lesson while knowing
almost nothing about the things denji
would actually do for money or while
continuing to argue with him after a few
tense moments for 22 where they both
tell each other to go to hell which I
would just say is probably a massive
foreshadowing in itself as I believe
that she should really turn dingy into a
weapon after he leaves though she stands
there alone for a moment and confirms to
herself that she isn't a loser like
dingy and will continue to and will
continue to contribute to the devil
Hunters Club somehow back in the club
room now ASA takes out her mum's phone
looking for a signal which of course got
all of the group members excited when
USA manages to find a signal bar for
like one second she immediately
stretches out her arm in an attempt to
find it again but as everyone Combs with
just how lucky they are and that they're
all going to be saved USA just ends up
tripping over her own fate and falls to
the ground yes guess what like it
probably would have been fine if this
wasn't some bung ass flip phone but Jen
who mum's skimping out on the modern
devices her phone snapped in half as it
fell to the ground looking at just how
pathetic USA actually is haruka's size
and comments that he expected better
from her instead ASA complains all the
time failing to come through and clutch
and always leading them down hearing
this is a panics and immediately leaves
the room to cry in isolation outside
lying down now USA Ponders whether the
aquarium is from hell since once you get
in there's no way out the hallway goes
on endlessly you can't even flush
toilets here and to top things off the
fishes started rotting in their tanks
this morning having moved into the
hallway himself Haruka throats of
abusive ASA for breaking his cell phone
earlier or else they would have actually
escaped USA believes that Haruka is
chainsaw man and asks why he doesn't
just do something in that case which
actually confuses him as he wonders like
what the hell she's even talking about
pointing out this starter on his chest
Haruka clarifies that they started as a
surgical implant and it's one of the
reasons why many people say that he's
the person who comes closest to chainsaw
man that's why he's the president of the
Chainsaw man society High School chapter
runner up and the chainsaw man quiz Show
contest and owner of every piece of
Chainsaw man merchandise bro as an utter
simp for chainsaw man anyway just to
make sure she's correct I said ask
Haruka about being chainsaw man one last
time to watch he starts hysterically
laughing while telling her that if he
was chained to a man they could have
broken out of the hell hole in no time
at all seconds after he then became
screaming for changed man to come and
save him seems in a fat SOS signal to
denji who's right around the corner
yarning with Yoshida as the toes stand
there on silent Yoshida speaks up about
how it's a boy Dinges cue to help ASA
dingy on the other hand reveals that he
was able to kill the devil last time
because the Devil Himself came at them
but the devil this time as nowhere to be
found so how can he even defeat it all
of a sudden Yoshida then reveals a cell
phone that he had also hidden but points
out that he hasn't been able to find his
signal and feels like it's been over
three days since they've been trapped
inside the aquarium and his eyes
everyone seems to have given up and
Yoshida himself has also made peace with
death This Time turning to dingy he asks
if chainsaw man would eat the death
devil for them leaving now man with a
spaced out look clueless as to what
Yoshida was even referring to as time
moves forth again dingy goes over to ASA
who's actually sitting inside of one of
the smaller fish tanks he notes that all
of the others are starting to lose it
but wonders how she's holding up
internally hearing that she's hungry
dingy just tells you to eat some fish
but she refuses claiming that she can't
eat it she also apologizes to dingy for
asking him out on a date explaining that
it's her fault how they ended up in the
situation and how dingy probably has no
idea that she's trying to turn him into
a weapon however now even starving and
pushed into a corner she just can't do
it she reveals that she doesn't have the
guts to do anything and has no idea
what's right or wrong her entire below
average life has just been one long
string of attempts to avoid any mistakes
and that's why she's just the total bore
didn't you not overly consumed with what
she's just muttering to herself sits
right in front of her and knows that
yeah she can't eat fish right then
flipping out of starfish as if it's like
the left leg of Exodia or something he
asks if Assa has ever tried this being
our big brain neurodivergent genius ASA
immediately protest as starfish dishes
are actually toxic and they have to be
boiled first before eating them of
course you know like our boy right here
is as resourceful as ever so they look
for a random pot lid and a pot to boil
those starfishes in while they're
cooking these starfishes now I should
notice there's tons of skull heads lying
right by her side Gingy reveals that he
collected these hats to sell them after
he gets out of the aquarium causing our
girl to question dingy's obsession with
money dingy clarifies that he just wants
to support his sort of friend you know
sort of little sister that's kind of
living with him at the moment dingy
being the Muppet he is believes that
naota is smart enough to actually go to
college and because of that is saving
for her tuition he also reveals to ASA
that before he got to where he is now
his life was super crappy and all he
wants is for her to have a normal one
soon the starfish is a fully boiled and
ready and the duo starts smashing them
back as I say is that feeding on these
starfishes isn't enough but looking over
to her right she notices dried fish and
after asking dingy tries to eat them she
hesitates at first but eventually
manages to Chow Down With Tears In Her
Eyes thinking that this was fun dingy
says that everything USA says is boring
but she's interesting to watch ASA is
confused by this statement until the
power of self-confidence hits her
causing her to stand up and say that
denji has a good eye for people and with
this new level of confidence flowing
through her she says that she's Charming
isn't she a simple dingy tells her How
He Loves Us attitude and reveals how it
reminds him of an old friend who's most
likely obviously power if you look into
the statement here a little bit May her
soul rest in peace after munching on the
dried fish ASA asks for dinji's help to
find a way out of the aquarium Asura
explains the plan which is nothing more
than to collect money rushing down the
hallway now dingy further discusses
their plan and how there is a thousand
yen and a backpack on the ground and
there is also a wallet with 14 000 Yen
inside it back at the lounge USA who was
previously giving denji a moral lesson
and theft now also wants to steal money
in order to escape the aquarium pushing
forth at Sean the sd2 robbed the
eternity devil over and over again again
they're having the best time of their
lives joking around and laughing
together after they're done collecting a
bag full of money like I think it's a
million yen ASA asks for the entire bag
didn't you hesitates at first since he's
given away such a large amount of money
like it's literally over a million yen
but she manages to persuade him by
saying that she'll Grant him any request
once they do Escape immediately dingy
then gives away all of the clicks of
money to ask her while grabbing the bag
she asks stingy to listen to her for now
so go over and stand in the corner with
his eyes closed and ears covered doing
exactly what he's told like these simply
is Digi walks over and stands up against
the wall telling himself to have some
confidence actually reminds herself that
regardless of how absurd the reason he
may seem It ultimately comes down to her
own perspective she urges herself to
have faith in her abilities and decides
to set aside the million Yin bag to
purchase the aquarium with her eyes
still closed and the bag along with
dingy seemingly vanished she places her
hand against the glass and commands the
aquarium spear
money is obviously a sensitive topic to
talk about but while dingy is still
skeptical about his decision of handing
over the money to ASA he still believes
that after obeying her he will get what
he wishes for so it's all good randomly
then she sees a penguin coming his way
so he reaches out and starts playing
with her suddenly dingy holding this
cute little penguin along with all of
these students appear outside of the
aquarium obviously this was thanks to
ASA who managed to weasel her way out of
the original conditions if you forgot
like the original conditions they were
that ASA had to kill the chainsaw man in
order to leave the aquarium as you know
obviously that was what the famine devil
told her right at the end of The Last
Arc anyway The Eternity devil then
randomly shows up right in front of her
and screams that this wasn't the deal
you can't buy an aquarium with a measly
1 million Yin seeing the devil towering
over ASA Yoshida quickly intervenes and
saves our girl having closed her eyes
previously as it transforms into yodu
who having read us his memories notes
that of course should feel guilty for
destroying an acquire him dirty net
worth the eternity people scream for her
to die however yodu easily manages to
defend himself with the aquarium Spear
and while getting ready to throw it asks
if the devil was sure one million wasn't
enough at last yoru sends the spear
flying forth which and a matter of
moments connects and sends a plethora of
sharks and other marine life flying
everywhere in turn this attack also
defeats the eternity devil and leaves
everyone nearby baffled with a change in
our sir atop a nearby building famine
remarks that well that idea went to hell
then looking down her eyes gaze catches
Yoshida and the two begin staring at
each other after the battle comes to a
conclusion ASA thanks denji for walking
her home while calling out the worst
date ever however surprisingly denji
actually enjoyed the day as he got to
touch a penguin in the end awkwardly
dingy brings up the request part again
and asks of USA would still Grant him
any request intrigued ASA asks him what
kind of request it was standing there
dingy was filled with excitement as he
proposed going on another date with our
sir you might have thought dingy was
going to ask for something load but no
he has his head set on straight for the
first time and his entire life with his
extensive dating experience he eagerly
volunteered to be her guide promising to
show her the ropes of creating the most
memorable and extraordinary outings well
I honestly don't know if he actually has
much dating experience all of it kind of
sums up to just him being with the most
dangerous woman in the verse but as his
face instantly lit up with a gentle
smile her heart beating rapidly with
anticipation it was at that moment that
yodu realized she might be on the verge
of actually falling in love however even
as Us's emotions swirled within her she
remained cautious putting up her guard
yodu confessed to ask her that she had
never expected to develop feelings for
someone as unconventional and Rough
Around the Edges as hum it's only
plausible because she shares in Us's
feelings as well still and her crazed
eyes she believes that they can continue
with the original plan confused utter
lowers who hid before randomly walking
forth and affectionately passing dingy's
head with her hand on his head it's
revealed that assambiodu had switched
places and in that moment she chants the
words dingy spinal cord sword but it
doesn't seem to work at all dingy's
confusion persisted as YOLO stood there
continuously petting him on the head
while saying denji spinal cord sword
expecting that to trigger a
transformation almost every lady Genji
has ever encountered has tried to
destroy him and turn him into a tall
funnily enough yodo's Effects Pro could
be fruitless leaving Genji perplexed and
unsure of what's even happening to him
attempting to make sense of the
situation denji gently patted user on
the head then while the same sense of
uncertainty copy the words as a spinal
cord sword before walking off and joking
that this was a fun way to say goodbye
later on and in a separate conversation
now Asurion Yodo exchanged thoughts on
DG's inability to transform despite the
a thirds well what can we say denji is
quite literally built different and on a
serious note though it was probably
something to do with her failing some
kind of way about a man now frustration
filled their voices as they mentioned
how annoying the situation was thinking
on it asked questions if it means to she
doesn't like her that way not that it
really matters since she totally doesn't
like him either nevertheless yodu points
out that they both share emotions which
is a new thing for her still they will
take their time to actually win dinge's
heart while searching for chainsaw man
on a larger scale yodu states that it's
probably best they get some sleep
however as it brings up the girl who
trapped everyone inside of the aquarium
and if she was related to yadu yodu
clarifies that she was the famine devil
and she actually hadn't seen her in a
while hence why she didn't recognize her
initially exhausted from their efforts
yodu collapses on their beard wanting to
rest however ASA even mindful of
personal hygiene offered a
well-intentioned suggestion she gently
advised yodu to take a bath before
settling down to sleep later after doing
so ASA and yoru then went back to beard
her mind consumed by thoughts of dingy
and the conflicting emotions his words
had stood within her she pondered over
his heartfelt Expressions spoken
seemingly and contradiction to his lack
of fondness for her as his frustration
grew fueled by the belief that if dingy
truly did dislike her he shouldn't have
seen such a sincere and compassionate
statement she wrestled with the
complexity of their relationship finally
ending on the take that she's quite
unsatisfied with how irritating he is
and actually hates him after a while and
probably the next day after class as he
goes out and reunites with his Squad
where dingy shares the ideas of his
super best date ever didn't you suggest
the idea that he and ASA should watch
mummy movies non-stop till 2am but only
2 000 Yen two thousand Yin though that's
like 20 bucks and in USA's eyes renting
movies out would be much easier and more
convenient she also shares the fact that
she doesn't like pricey dates slightly
bummed out that she didn't go with his
plan initially didn't she agreed to her
plan and panics when USA suggests going
over to his place since it's even
cheaper that way born away with like the
changing events then she awkwardly tells
ASA that there will be a few rules she
has to follow if she does come over
whether questioning this he reveals that
you can't break these rules no matter
what because if you do and the worst
case scenario it could result in her
death sneaking out behind the duo heroka
who had been eavesdropping on the
conversation get deluted when he hears
dingy mention that someone can die
the much away today had finally arrived
when a girl was scheduled to visit
dinji's humble abode as anticipation
filled the air dingy took a moment to
caution Asda about a rule named
unbreakable rule one he emphasized the
importance of refraining from opening
any other apartment door ensuring that
their privacy and the sanctity of their
neighbor's spaces were respected as us
stepped inside our simple dingy guided
her towards the Cozy seating area right
in front of the television just as the
excitement settled in did you revealed
the existence of a second rule which is
to refrain from opening the refrigerator
but I already knew all too well the
common sense of never invading the
sacred territory of another person's
fridge while the atmosphere brumming
with curiosity and amusement danger
proceeded to disclose the most vital
rule which he shared the delightful news
that his roommate a lover of furry
friends had ventured out to walk their
beloved dogs he also added how his
roommate as somewhat of a problem child
so no matter what happens Isa is
prohibited to make out with him in front
of her sitting there and congratulate
getting more and more annoyed as to
start sarcastically asking dingy whether
he thinks she likes him to which things
you respond that he's been thinking
about how she asked him out on a date so
I figured that she must 90 like him
without any further discussion as he
goes defensive mode and clarifies that
there is no way she likes him in fact
it's actually the contrary she hates
stingy more than anything as he reveals
that just like denji she also has rules
and this one is that he needs to stay
away from her or else he'll just end up
dead in an attempt to divert Ninja's
attention away ASA confesses that she
initially agreed to the date with denji
as in memes of distracting herself
feline tended to leave right after
watching the movie together as time
passes the weight of this Revelation
finally Dawns on dinchy causing him to
question whether ASA had been using him
all along doubt begins to creep into his
mind wondering whether he's somehow been
at fault for all of the current
predicaments as all of these thoughts
foiled in dinged his head he can't help
but recall a distant memory someone had
once remarked that he smelled like dog
but rather than taking a fan to it he'd
mistaken it for a compliment now in deep
thought he wonders if there was more to
that common than he initially thought as
his unique scent played a role in the
way others perceive him the question
languages on his mind adding another
layer of self-doubt to his already
Tangled emotions as dinchy thinks about
his complicated situation he came to a
simple conclusion USA must dislike him
because of the way he smells despite
this despite this did he couldn't deny
the fact that he's he did slightly like
her but if this is how it is then that's
that and honestly that's how that's how
it is for guys most of the time well at
least that's how it was for me if a girl
turned around and was like I don't like
you it's like well ah damn that kind of
sucks but I guess I gotta move on and
try something else no idea if she was
actually being serious or not anyway
with a resolution to improve himself he
decided to stop sleeping with the dogs
which is actually insane in my opinion
for someone who sleeps with dogs however
just as he contemplated the absurdity of
these changes which is like of course he
does a surprising twist occurred USA
transformed into yodu leaned forth and
originally kiss them out of the blue
ninji's mind reeled with astonishment
trying to make sense of the sudden
turnover being slay man is like what's
going on this was his one and only dream
yet before he could fully comprehend the
situation the door suddenly opened and a
pack of dogs entered the apartment
turning around and screaming as the dogs
began running for them they notice a
short shadowy figure standing in a
doorway then just when this situation
really couldn't get any worse naota had
appeared and guess what she came back to
the apartment and witnessed denji's lewd
makeout session with a good old Arthur
over here pointing her finger forth and
while calling us Ray Thief a random
chain appears from the top of her finger
that shoots forth and implants itself
directly into the brain of the war devil
to denji's astonishment yadu immediately
hops on all fours and fearlessly
Unleashed her own in a dog backing back
at the Rowdy canines in front of her
what called her boy more off guard
though was the fact that yodu's bikes
proved to be a secret weapon silencing
all of the dogs and leaving him utterly
dumbfounded with the change in this
human Naruto having one tested or burst
out into an evil kind of laughter
annoyed dingy who somehow didn't figure
it all out demands to know what naosa
had done to watch the child proclaims
that she had turned her into a dog then
she depends the reasoning as to why
she'd even do that and nayuta just
casually states that it's because she
put spit on her property baffled Genji
screams that he's he's literally his own
property and demands that she turned his
friend back thus instant NATO though
denies it to start with but after dingy
offers to cook her something she agrees
to turn you back later as time skipped
forth it shown that like every other
puppy yodu had fallen asleep between the
dogs were cuddling them on the other
hand denji and naota have a meal amidst
their own chaos dingy asks naota to turn
a friend back into her original Self but
knowing that every girl Dinges ever met
has tried to kill him questions what
makes her different after hearing
denji's last reply NATO states that she
will return her to normal however only
with dinghy abides by two conditions
first she demands to be able to eat ice
cream every day while the other requires
dingy to never get friendly with Asa
naos is reasoning for this is that she
simply doesn't like us as scent dingy
asks if she smells like a wet dog
obviously man's just trying to reconfirm
his previous doubts and they'll just
screams back at him that wet dogs
actually smell nice to fix everything
that has happened back at their
apartment though Neosho explains that
she'll alter Us's memory so she thinks
ninja stood her up back at school then
she gets a bit worried about this since
ASA might end up hating on him but
they're able to reiterate that he's done
with her either way so it's not like
that even matters after completing the
memory alteration we see Usher standing
right in front of her High School
thinking that dingy had stood her up
confused with it all yodu just pushes
her feelings aside and thinks it's best
that they start targeting a different
boy on the way home now she doubts
herself thinking that he must have
forgotten not that she'd even actually
like care about that this was all the
warned dingy just like just to stay away
from her to begin with not like not that
she totally liked him or anything she
totally didn't mean to spend that much
money on dating Plus she also had to do
her school homework so as she was kind
of glad that she got stood up here
nevertheless she confesses to herself
and acknowledges this feeling of longing
to experience even the tiniest desire
for human contact but also realizes that
such emotion arose solely due to being
alone with someone of the opposite
gender for an extended duration of time
so basically those were her hormones
talking at the end of the day Isis
priority is to beat chainsaw man and
gets her body back which means there's
no reason for Usher to be stuck on dingy
especially since she actually prefers
Solitude more than anything else and
that way Isom might actually have an
easier time attaining her own personal
happiness without relying on dingy after
a while and having returned to the
school like a complete Muppet she starts
to wonder what the hell is even wrong
with her all she should care about is
getting her body back damn Fujimoto man
I don't know why but these writings just
always seem to resonate with me on like
a different kind of level they're all
enveloping fear of loneliness just I
think it just strikes some kind of chord
within me could be the fact that set
within a black shadowy box and record
these videos all day but either way
breaking through their awkwardness
Yoshida randomly shows up asking what's
wrong with USA and why is she standing
there then continuing with your
Shooter's random randomness he steps
forth and asks as she'd like to keep him
company for a birds so that that brings
us to the end of this dating dingy Arc
and the second Arc and or second or
third Arc in part two of Chainsaw man
it's getting super confusing right now
tatsuki with how you are deciding to
switch things up with these different
parts to your story and everything but
rereading the section of Chainsaw man
Fuller made me realize just how similar
both Arthur and dingy are like the
personalities are Polar Opposites but
the experiences they seem to go through
are super similar and I'm enjoying it so
far just watching Arthur having to like
experience The Eternity devil and then
being turned into a dog like dingy was
as well and it's just all these all
these little things anyway next time
we're actually getting back into the
hands in a little bit more of an
exciting Arcane on this one was probably
a bit of a dull Arc for those who are
hoping that some hands happened it was
more of just like a character building
Arc next time and hopefully soon I'll be
back with the falling devil Arc so if
you are interested and want me to like
keep up to date with chainsaw man then
leave a like and try and help me in
pushing this video to 5 000 likes as it
just shows that you guys are super keen
on like those specific series also if
you are new around here and want content
just like this but for a multitude of
different series then make sure to
subscribe but either way for now it's
being a professional degenerate dear
Volo and I'll see you all in eight Birds
bye